regular chess its regular chess time
2-minute nimzo-indian land maybe or BOGO
Indian the BOGO Indian in full effect
let's try that looking to control the
center with pieces one day
let's go Bishop let's make a --sold I
don't have to worry about a bishop in
and around for with this and then trying
to establish pawns on dark c5 Knight
here to a5 or if a force plate now think
about c6 a5 and then C 5 I really don't
want to allow that pond to get here so
let's do this Knights ok and do that
pawn push I'm gonna do this now since
the knight isn't controlling that Square
and oh crap I should have I would really
like to have my knight right here not
much time though oh ok let's go here I'm
looking for this and this bishop could
find itself in a difficult spot if I
have a pawn cemented on this square I'm
not sure about f4 but who has time to
think in these positions any huh it's
time to think anyhow how about this
looking for a pawn push okay now I could
take here and I think I want to hang on
to this pawn or could I say you know
what who cares about that guy actually
no I like him too much
I don't know maybe I just play here yeah
definitely here right now and then if
it's attacked I could play back
if I could do pawn push now let's come
over here I guess this pond is ready to
or that the file is ready to open up and
okay what's the time situation okay let
me think a little bit let me think a
little bit I really don't want to weak
in my position too much I'm gonna do
this and then plant my bishop here no no
no no I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna
play my knight here first or maybe this
yeah that's an idea this pond is gonna
get killed real soon let's do this King
up rook lift or not a rook lift rook to
AJ and then maybe something on the H
file yeah that's gonna be my plan no
wait actually now I can't make use of g6
I wanted to watch out for this soon as
the knight moves I have this available
you guys should do this move I'm gonna
do that move I want to hang on to him no
time though there's there's no time now
for white as soon as I move this Bishop
there's tension between these rooks I
like this move keep my Queen right where
it's at that was forgotten it's trouble
I want to open up the H file get up on
here and then my queen over to h2 but
the knight is around to defend might be
seeing resign the knight is running
short on squares rook here double rooks
look at the h1 square and that's gonna
be it no time all right good game let's
back up maybe there's some quick point
that could be offered for my side or
your side bogo Indian if you're trying
to learn war tried out I think I I
referenced the the names of the openings
when that when they're played so there's
clearly no in-depth analysis going on
here but if you're interested in
learning more about it at least they
have the names right here after if
Knight c3 and Bishop before that's
called an Enzo Indian after night here
and Bishop b4 it's called a BOGO Indian
it's hyphenated
I think both would come up in a search
online but anyhow BOGO Indian territory
with this pawn structure not so sure
about the Queen move maybe the eventual
move you played the knight move maybe
that could be played instead and then
try to get an F 3 e4 I wonder I don't
know what else was I thinking here I
felt pretty comfortable as soon as that
pond pushed because I'm getting ready to
do this and it's either I push or it's
it's a tough spot I think I have my
pieces and a good in a good area I
wonder if you could look into this as
well after you push right now maybe
consider a4 a5 and don't challenge this
pawn just yet just keep it as is and
look look forward to this a 4a a4 a5
idea if the F file and the e-file aren't
opening up I'm not sure what I'll have
at least in the immediate future maybe I
could or as white you could look into f3
as soon as I'm threatening to maybe play
this efore move successfully then maybe
you could have f3 and and so you could
always be in a spot in other words to me
efore with f4 the main idea here for
black is to maybe try and establish a
pawn on e4 and then follow up with let's
say Knight to e5 but if you're having a
pawn on F 3 and E 4 is played you do
have that f4 response you know I will
not be able to make use of that v square
of course so anyhow just some turnaround
some some of my thoughts from that
particular structure